hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
the inhibitory role of specific
macrophages
in rcc i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labberts
and sponsored by vizia farm for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
viziofarm.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen i
will now
turn the presentation over to brandon
hopkinson to introduce our speaker for
today
brandon welcome sir
hello and thanks for joining us today my
name is brandon hopkinson i'm a product
marketing manager here at vizio farm
and i'll be your moderator for this
lecture today we have dr
alfreda nursnell head of the
immunoanalytics research group at the
helmholtz institute
and a professor at the lunewick
maximilianist university in munich
she is a board certified immunologist
with special expertise in antigen
presentation
and t cell modulation during today's
webinar she'll discuss the inhibitory
role of macrophages
in immune oncology with a focus on renal
cell carcinoma
thank you very much for your time today
dr nursnell and i'm excited for the
presentation
so i'll let you take it from here please
begin whenever you're ready
thank you very much for this very nice
introduction and i welcome you all
to today's webinar and the title is the
inhibitory role of macrophages in
in immuno-oncology and the renal cell
carcinoma
i will start with the current status of
immunotherapy or cancer oncology therapy
and i introduce you to the new
area of immuno oncology this is with two
new therapies the adoptive t cell
transfer
and the checkpoint inhibition here shown
the checkpoint inhibition
and what is new about it and what's the
new area about
is that now we can achieve long-term
control
of tumors even in metastatic situation
as you can see in the top
so for patients who have failed all
therapies
now there are options to really to
to achieve long-term remission and
durable responses
and here shown in green is the survival
curve
of epilimumab and in blue then the
warm-up monotherapies two checkpoint
inhibitors
the immunotherapy started a new
paradigma in tumor therapy
it's no longer like with current or
classical cancer therapies
that the tumor cells are the direct
target of therapeutic
inhibition like chemotherapy
tyrosine kinase inhibitors or antibtf
therapy they target the tumor cells
directly and kill them
however tumor cells who do not have the
target molecule
they are resistant and the tumors will
eventually
grow out immunotherapy
is we mobilize our own defense system
to fight the tumor cell as we do all
know is the immune system
is dysfunctional in the tumor
microenvironment and the new therapeutic
applications reactivate
those existing t-cells by releasing the
brake
with anti-ctla-4 or anti-pd-1 pdl1
checkpoint antibodies
the consequence is that the t cells will
become reactivated and now can
kill and destroy the tumor cells the
second therapy
is adoptive t cell transfer of
engineered t
cells where the t cells are equipped
with new anti with new
receptors like the chimeric antigen
receptors
which we know as the cd19 car
t cells for the treatment of leukemia
and lymphoma
here new t cells are given to the
patient
and they can direct directly attack
and destroy the tumor cells this
new therapy was possible through
scientific knowledge
by two seminal research scientists
jim allison and casuko honjo
who discovered tim allison discovered
the ctla-4
in 1987 and he recognized
that by inhibiting the interaction of
ctla4 which
with its ligand can initiate an immune
response
horny discovered the pd-1 and discovered
or
recognized that this is a negative
regulator of immune response
and the scientific knowledge was
translated to clinical application by
the development
of a number of different monoclonal
antibodies
the voluma pembrolizumab attack
and so on there is now a number of
therapeutic antibodies
which are active and effective in
clinical application
so the mode of action is that like
anti-pd1 or antipedial one
they release the break in the effector
phase so in the tumor microenvironment
with the consequence
that more tumor cells are killed with
existing specificity
anti-ctla-4 works in the priming in the
initiation phase of the immune response
it takes out the break in the priming
phase
leading that more t-cells and t-cells
with new specificities are being
generated
the advantage of the new specificities
is
that now additional tumor cells can be
killed
however that has also the risk of
autoimmunity because maybe possibly
also self cells are being killed
the current status with this new
development
is that we can achieve long-term tumor
control
in a number of tumor entities we have
those tumors that respond very strongly
like
hodgkin's disease or merkel cell
carcinoma we have most tumors
who respond intermediately like melanoma
lung cancer bladder cancer renal cell
cancer and so on
so it has to be noted that we have
responses across many tumor types
however there are some tumors like
pancreatic or prostate who do not
respond or do not respond
very well in general we have to say
that only a subgroup of patient responds
and the question is
who is a responder why are others
non-responders
and how can we turn a non-responder into
a responder
currently experiments are done with
combination therapies here shown on
tctla
4 and antipdl1 and you can see
the response rates are increased with
regards to
comparison epilimumab and nivolumab here
in green and blue
compared to the combination treatment
with molumplus epilimum up in yellow
however
still we have 40 non-responders
and i'll i highlight here that we have
a combination of two t-cell targeting
therapies
what i want to show you in the next
slide
that the immune system is much more
complex
than just having t cells to do the job
we need to know what the immune cells
are
required what they do need for rejection
and we have to find out case
individually
meaning personalized therapy where is
the problem
for that we have to look at the tissue
environment
and see actually what the current status
of the immune system is at the tissue
site
and how can we do that for that we have
to look at the tissue
we have to characterize the tissue
environment
and we have to find out not only the
number but also the type
and the functional orientation of the
immune system
we have to find out about the
localization of the immune cells
are they in the tumor core in the
invasive margin
in the stroma or even are they
in the metastatic site or in the primary
tumor
and finally we also have to find out
whether the immune cells communicate
with each other
and how and what they communicate about
how can we do that how can we define the
immune
contextual those of type density
quality localization communication we
have
we can take the tissue dissociate it
and acquire the tear so the tumor
infiltrating immune cells
and do a flow cytometry analysis by that
we can find out what type of t cell is
what
type of immune cell is there and as an
example for the renal cell cancer
we have about a one to one ratio of t
cells and myeloid cells
so it's not only t cells which are in
the tissue
present then we have a small number of
nk cells meaning natural killer cells
and b
cells with this type of analyses
we can have a deep insight into how
and what type of immunes are there but
what we do not gain
is where are they located and do they
communicate
for that we have to look at the tissue
we have to look
into the tissue site where actually the
communication might take place
and by that we can see that as an
example the renal cell carcinoma we have
t
cells here stained in red and cases
again stained in red but we also have a
number of myeloid cells but
different markers and we can also see
that they do have different localization
for example the dc lamp positive
lymphocytes
leukocytes are focally oriented when the
other ones are dispersed
the different immune cell types they
also do have
different functional consequences and
the importances with regards to the
rival
here we're looking at colorectal cancer
crc or renal cell cancer tissue
we look at the cd8 t cells and we can
see
here that the number of the cd8 t cells
in the colorectal cancer has a positive
predictive value for survival while for
renal cell cancer
it has a negative predictive value the
curves always
the ones in red and k cells for example
quite differently have a positive
predictive value
in real cell cancer and have no value in
colorectal cancer the diesel and
positive till
again in the colorectal cancer they have
a positive predictive value
in the renal cell concept they have a
negative predictive value
so the different immune cell types they
can have different prognostic value
depending on the tissue
type and how can we
further use this knowledge
for the benefit of the patient so we in
our lab
we looked at a different type of myeloid
cell that expresses
the marker dc sign this is a marker for
interstitial
so tissue resident myeloid cells as we
can find them
in the tumor tissue we observed
that myeloid cells with the cd2 or nine
surface marker which we call earth dc
because they are particularly frequent
in renal cycle carcinoma
earth meaning enriched in vinelcy
carcinoma
and we observed that a high number of
myeloid cells with this marker cd 209
indicates a poor prognosis so the curve
in red
high earth dc number meaning poor
survival probability
while patients with tumors with low
earth dc numbers have a better survival
probability and
with regards therapeutic consequences we
have to consider what the mode of action
is of these
myeloid cells why are they
contributing to a poor survival is it
because they are directly
tumor promoting by secreting factors
like fetch f
tgf beta il-10 or inhibitory
surface molecules or is it because they
communicate with other cells like a t
cell and as an example they might
have surface molecules that are
inhibitory to t
cells so preventing the lytic activity
of the t
cell destroying the tumor cell
and that has a therapeutic consequence
if we consider pd1 pd1
checkpoint inhibition therapy the so
this interaction of pd1 with pdl1 is
also a negative signal
and by checkpoint antibodies we take out
this negative signal if we have
macrophages providing also a negative
signal
this will prevail even in the presence
of checkpoint inhibition therapy
meaning we have resistance to checkpoint
therapy
because the macrophages still are
inhibitory
so we have to find out is there indeed a
communication
between these two cell types in the
tissue
and we looked adrenal cell carcinoma
tissue by
chromogenic double
immunohistology like cd3 in blue
and cd209 in brown so our myeloid cells
and we do see that these two cell types
are indeed
very adjacent to each other so we can
assume
that they communicate and we would like
to know actually what do they
communicate
and for that we need to stain a few more
markers
and for that we do need to
get into a more multiplex
immunohistology
with using fluorescently fluorescently
labeled antibodies and this if so
immunofluorescence and
immunohistology provides the
opportunity to use more than two markers
and like here we stained cd3 for the t
cell in blue the macrophage in green
and a third marker foxo which is a
transcription factor
and this transfriction factor is known
to provide cell cycle arrest it is also
known
to drive the t cells away from effective
function
so inhibiting their killing activity
and when you look now at this a multiple
stained
immuno fluorescent stained tissue
section
we find a situation where a t cell is
adjacent to the macrophage
and another t cell is not adjacent to a
macrophage
and if we look at these two different t
cells
for the expression of the transcription
factor foxo
we can see that foxo is expressed in the
t
cell that is adjacent to a macrophage
and it's not
expressed in the t cell that is not
adjacent to a microphage
and this information provides us with
the knowledge
that indeed the macrophage may
communicate something negatively to the
t
cell and potentially inhibiting the t
cell
so we can assume that the
tumor-associated macrophages are indeed
inhibitory cells in the tumor
microenvironment
and by that they are relevant targets in
oncology
there is a number of publications that
indicate this concept that the
macrophages may limit chemotherapy it
may
limit immunotherapy and that they
are by that interesting targets in
oncology
if we know that they communicate with t
cells
we do also know that a therapy that is
directed
towards activating the t cells cannot by
itself
be optimally active
therefore targeting strategies to
remove to change to eliminate
macrophages may be beneficially combined
with checkpoint inhibition
again multiplex phenotyping of the
tissue
provides the relevant information
whether or not
we have to do combination therapy and
what combination therapy
might be the most effective here shown
again an example of the renal cell
cancer
where we have on the top a
type of renal cell cancer that has high
microphage numbers like here the cells
in red and in green it's the t cells
so on the bottom we have an example
also for inside cancer that seem to have
very
little macrophages present
we can assume from this knowledge that
the top
patient with a tumor that has
macrophages we
likely expect resistance to checkpoint
monotherapy the bottom patient with a
tumor that has
very little macrophages we expect
that it's likely that this patient is
responsive to monotherapy
of checkpoint inhibition so it has a
consequence
what type of immune cells we have
present in the tissue type
in addition it is important to solve
and to recognize the spatial resolution
so whether the immune cells are directly
adjacent to the tumor
like here intraepithelial here
this lymphocyte is directly in the tumor
nest
whereas all the other lymphocytes here
are in the tumor stroma
so not really directly in contact to the
tumor cell
also with tissue phenotyping we can
determine whether we have communication
like in this situation where the
suppressor in red
is distance to the effector in green
so here we would assume communication
does not necessarily take place and we
do not have to consider
very strongly in therapy the subpresence
of the suppressor cell
quite differently to this tumor type
where the suppressor in red is directly
adjacent
to the effector in green where we do
expect
that we have to target both cell types
to get a beneficial
therapeutic outcome and finally
we do not want to only look at a very
tiny slice of the tissue because the
adjacent
tissue may be different so we want to
scan
the whole type the whole section of the
tissue
to really completely harvest the
information that the tissue provides us
and you will recognize immediately
now we really have to get digital we
have to have a good
screening system a computer assisted
digital observation of the tissue to
really harvest everything that the
tissue tells us for the benefit of the
patient
this is my last slide i thank you for
your attention
i hope i could communicate to you the
importance to find out the complexity of
the immune system in the tissue type
and i hope i could also show you that
although we all believe
that our eyes are the best evaluation
system
we do need in the future to look broader
and to help our own personal
evaluation by computer computer-assisted
technologies thank you for attention
great thank you very much for the
excellent presentation well using
digital image analysis especially for
those complex immuno oncology questions
can really detail out the players in
those systems
we would like to thank both dr nurse now
for her time as well as everyone who
watched today's presentation
if you have any questions please feel
free to contact us at webinars
visiofarm.com or check out our other
webinars or additional content
available in the knowledge library on
the vizio farm website
thanks again and have a great day
thank you brandon and we would like to
once again thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
all questions asked will be addressed by
our speaker via the email address that
you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to thank labyrinth and our sponsor
vizio farm for underwriting today's
educational webcast
you can view this webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
be sure to join us for our next webinar
sponsored by vizio farm
development and analytical validation of
prognostic biomarkers
for metastasis on february 9th at 9 00
am pacific
12 pm eastern that's all for now
until next time thanks for joining us
bye-bye